andy and astro while you're at it the
king of the hill challenge the finals
going down right now
tasty steve mark man and we got our next
match this is loser's side
somebody is going home is it accu major
and the brian or
is it el negro and the other ninja on
his squad master raven this is what i
like to see character variety
looking pretty good right now round one
fight all right starting it off master
raven
right into the action goes for the big
sweep early on
acumen let's see what he's going to do
defensively how is he going to approach
this matchup wow
look at that look at this damn watch
this damage though keep the damage
though
even oh the power question on the back
turn and
she definitely got a buff this season so
you have to respect the back turn
options from master raven a little more
250 50 coming out of that bad boy and
that's another move that that uh i-10
counter hit attack there
able to capitalize okay big pick up here
uh
uh uh wall uh uh uh
i got damage too
oh big counter hit this round looking a
little different and it's looking better
for accu major one
round a piece oh this is gonna be good
this is gonna be good
ooh here we go get the low
oh my gosh back turn got to be careful
how this is playing out
accu major starting to make the push has
the wall this is again a big advantage
for brian oh do they switch positions
i like that you don't get it's not a lot
of characters big counter hit to get a
chance to switch sides like that
doesn't matter though big pick up by
accu major looking for the turn on the
wall
and still gets to cancel good defense no
punish on the wild rising one
oh what a block fisherman slam somewhere
jimmy j tran would be proud gets the
combo and the round ender
two rounds to one el negro needs to
change it up
continuing forward nice low parry
big damage nice okay option right there
on the wall once again
going from that back turn power crush
oh hatchet do it again
no back one there's the hatchet
oh my god oh god i'm ducking but he
misses the combo following
the full streak extension what is going
on here today
oh they're doing it they're doing oh
what's he doing he went for the back too
don't have to do it again
oh the blue stuff and the slope yo let
me see it in the chat
let me see that blue stuff in the chat
though if you got him show him
it was blue and it was slow motion steve
i couldn't breathe
it was blue oh my gosh
here we go pushing towards the wall
again big opportunity master raven with
the damage
wait what goes for the mix-up back turn
mm-hmm
drop him from the top good block oh my
gosh she's using the pinion step
i like how you uh properly stay said the
penis step el negro takes it
like i said you get two ways to taunt
one is the
actual time and the key charge el negro
takes first game
from accu major that is big yo shout
outs to everybody all you taste buds in
the chat
using that blue stuff i see you out
there el negro takes
first game yo we should definitely have
some friendly wagers going
right now we need to get a mod in here
making wagers
i would love to know what you guys think
who do you think is going to take it
from this set accu major versus el negro
going down right now
also shout out to you boom squad users
out there dropping the blue stuff in the
chat as well i see you guys
man these matches are gonna be sick this
first one
already already heating up this is what
i like
yeah and again if you guys have been
watching make sure you guys stay tuned
there's a lot more
tech in action on the way we're in the
middle of our top eight here for the
king of the hill finals my name is mark
and i'm here with tasty steve
and again we have a special announcement
later on today so make sure you guys
stay tuned it's going to be fun
it's going to be fun just like these
matches have been fun just like the fun
i'm sure all the people out there have
been having watching the king of the
hill finals
this is something a collimation of the
community series that bandai namco
uh being esports has put together and it
has been amazing there's been numerous
tournaments held by community figures
myself
included tastebud bouts we've already
seen them and
all across the community we've seen uh
these events go down
uh combat combat combat now that is
really hard to say
uh taste bud bout um we even saw kawhi
face miles actually had
a tournament as well just so many people
cuddle core um and now we've come to
this where we've seen all these
players play throughout all of them um
and now we have the finals of course we
have had our king of the hill
champion in glaciating uh for the most
part but that's what makes this so
exciting that's why these matches are so
good we're gonna get back to the losers
side of things as we get to this next
match el negro going up against axi
major
oh and you know accumature he loves it
it's the mishima building
i love it too you gotta turn up my
symphony steve turn it up in my
headphones and my quality astro
headphones mm-hmm
turn up my headphones i got the power
all right here we go this is big okay so
right now
and there goes up 1-0 right now if he's
able to win here it's going to be all
over for accu major because this is a
loser's bracket however acu major
he's proven to be a very strong
competitor that we've seen throughout so
many of these online tournaments
i would not doubt it in my mind if you
can make a comeback here
he's blocking all these key moves here
it's really giving acting major a hard
time
of trying to open up and get the uh get
just get the momentum in the match up oh
here's the flow
oh gets the floats gonna get scared no
damage that carry
uh oh big damage oh no you spent it on
that was what you bit spit it on i don't
agree
you know there's a different kind of
meter it doesn't show on screen
sometimes it's like i can
i can get away with it and el negro is
definitely using that in the matchup
right now he's going for some crazy
stuff
i like accu major playing a little
further back still the low parry from el
negro and master ray
damage on the wall always taking that
oaky
looking for the tech in a lot of
situation oh situations
oh my gosh oh big damage
just had to make sure it was working the
battery
power crush just slightly out of range
again
surf ninjas
and risk getting hit by another this
guy's a bad man it's crazy man
it's crazy man it's crazy all right here
we go
feel the rhythm feel the right oh he got
the second hit
going to get the wall again no
then oh was looking just looking for the
back fool
option and i like that you can see el
negro kind of like set that up for
you know a whole match at this point
making that look i love that move
making the move a little bit more
powerful prevalent especially going for
the low option out of back turn gets the
combo started
damage is really high on the wall for
master rape and this might be it
oh whoa the herota care package the
stimulus package just kicked in
check your mail make sure to make
corrado no uh
oh my god what i said he's gonna win
he's gonna win
he's going to do it all right that q
major one round away from here tying it
up here
and he's at the top of the building oh
oh oh my gosh
master raven just cashing in on all the
damage good block green punish
patch it do it again i said do it again
oh no that was 4-3 counter hit accu
major back in the game this is big
damage on the table
uh but it ain't over yet oh but it ain't
over yet
the wall oh the low just to get it
started man that was getting scary
that tech was going to be something
crazy because i'ma tell you right now i
felt like if el negro
smelled that any earlier we would have
been talking about a completely
different match we still would have been
commentating it but accumajor
gets the wits about brian brings it back
second game we got one more match
we got ourselves a real match it's gonna
go down to this final game between these
two
and i can't even call it you know these
guys have been playing at such a crazy
pace
whoever gets at the wall but then out of
nowhere you know sometimes the positions
flip
and just out of nowhere you know someone
else is going to get the advantage it's
crazy and again both of these guys
killers as far as you know maximizing
the opportunities against the wall
against their opponent
man um i feel like this is one of the
good the rare opportunities i get to
talk about the the wall damage that
master raven has not only the wall
damage
but um just the oaky that she can force
in so many situations and i feel like el
negro is going for that a lot more
um and trying to like kind of call it
out and i feel like acumen just kind of
odds with that too because we know brian
is a hey did you just tech
eat this taunt jet upper monster right
even more so accumulator himself right
so it's not only just about the
character it's just the fact that we
know
accumulator will catch you taking with
the back four we'll catch you taken with
a taunt jet upper and we'll test that
and master raven doesn't have a mix up
as strong as that
but being able to call out some of those
situations whether it be back turn and
use the power crush
back turning use the counter back turn
it use the low back turn
like so many options that she can force
you to where you really don't want to
test
uh taking in some options acumen you're
bringing it back
we're going into a game number three and
remember somebody is going home from
this ladies and gentlemen
master raven going up against brian game
number three
somebody's gonna get sad after this when
i can tell you that i tell you what
all right here we go this is gonna be it
the final match here we're in the open
arctic snowfall here
the stage that has been selected
i mean i don't know this is too hard to
call steve
this is loser again loser of this is out
of the tournament they got her breaking
throws in the snow
oh oh and look
actually taking advantage of how
aggressive acu major is being
getting a big launcher right there and
like i said that back turn against
is definitely a problem and the launcher
right here el negro can close out
oh just a little bit the final hit
that's the most fulfilling thing ever
when the last hit of your combo gets the
kill you're like
as intended is just enough my
calculations were correct
and just like that last time same
launcher same starter goes for this okie
and looking for a duck right there the
low perry working out el negro
with the lead running away with it i
mean it's been momentum so far for el
negro the entire way he has been
controlling
the pace of the matchup but a big
counter hit from accu major he drops the
combo
unfortunately there he's gonna have to
be very careful but a
nice punishment i like it he was locked
and loaded ready for that
okay needs to be clear for the drive
that was a big risk i like how he pulled
that off there he was able to get the
hatchet kick and close things out
tied up on rounds oh wow the jet upper
oh my god
accu major running it back the third
round get up three they are straight
fighting right now
fighting in the snow all right here we
go goes for the lows still just chopping
away
look at that gets the dropping from the
top here's the follower he does have
rage though he caught him once again
this time breaking out of it
yeah that one plus two throws got to be
ready hatchet do it again
went for the four three four three
actually clips out of the air gonna get
a scale combo looks for the okie
oh my gosh no opportunity there
follow-up gets the punish down jab once
again goes for the tracking move the
blue stuff with
the blue stuff over the hatching kick el
negro
let me see that blue stuff in the chat
that's my chair my bad i'm sorry i
didn't know what that was i heard him
that was crazy
that rage drive was clutch
oh down back too i love that one just
run up puncher in the stomach
this is big good opportunity gonna put
him into another blender mix up
what is it decides to just wait oh
my gosh that might be at steve uh uh
dead
el negro takes out ag acu major
sending brian out of the tournament
moves on
on the loser's side el negro wow man
what a set that was actually sick
we don't see people fight el negro like
that we don't see people actively
uh not el negro but uh accumen excuse me
we don't see people fight um
accu major like that because we know um
acu major has a tendency to call you out
with great pokes
um as well as just to challenge your
text in a lot of situations with those
back fours
with those taunt jet uppers and this
time just not able to
stop el negro from attacking i feel like
it's one of those things where you fight
brian it's really easy to get kind of
like steamrolled and put in the
situation where you're taking and your
backs to the wall and you don't know
what to do
i feel like el negro playing at that
speed actually made it so it was a lot
harder for aki major to get the game
started in his name
and i feel like that's why el negro will
be and has
uh has moved on in this tournament yeah
definitely a clash of styles between the
two but again
it was nice to see how they were able to
come out on top you know accumulator out
of the tournament again
has played so well during the entire
community series so i gotta